und für uns in leipzig ist mein kollege
til biermann vor ort will wärmt gerade
gesehen heute sind leipzig zum glück
nicht ganz so viel los wie ist die lage
aktuell bei dir geschrieben hier in der
großen fleischer gasse nahe des zentrums
hier haben sich ca 1000 demonstranten
die gegen die korona maßnahmen
demonstrieren versammelt sie wurden hier
von der polizei quasi eingeschlossen
denn es gibt ja viele gegen proteste von
politischen links stehenden leuten
antifaschisten die sich hier um
gesammelt haben und dagegen
demonstrieren wollen
demonstrationen stattfinden sollte die
aber nicht stattfinden konnte war wegen
einem einem attest ein masken befreiungs
attest was was es da der hintergrund nun
es gibt ja also die allermeisten
demonstranten tragen keine masken da sie
offenbar nicht daran glauben dass es
sinnvoll ist und es gibt dann auch so
gerüchte dass es ja gesundheitsschädlich
seien eine maske zu tragen und deswegen
haben sich viele leute atteste besorgt
von ärzten die ihnen sagen
dieser test die ihnen erlauben ohne
maske unterwegs seien allerdings scheint
es so zu sein dass viele leute sich da
irgendwelche formulare aus dem internet
herunterladen und dieser tessellation da
ist sehr schwer ist glaube ich so ein
attest zu bekommen und es war immer so
dass der anmelder der demo sohn
gefächert es hatte und deswegen durfte
die demo dann nicht stattfinden
eine andere frage wie gesagt bisher ist
es relativ ruhig erwartet man trotzdem
dass das ganze noch irgendwie aus dem
ruder läuft
nun haben sich ein paar hooligan gruppen
hier auch eingefunden
nicht gerade ein paar glaube ich und das
kann sein dass irgendwann ist noch dazu
kommt dass die mit anderen mit
gegendemonstranten aufeinanderstoßen
die sind ja zurzeit wie man hier sieht
von der polizei voneinander getrennt
aber wir konnten auch beobachten wie
beide gruppen sich mit einem gitter
dazwischen gegenüber standen und sich
dann beschimpft haben also wenn die dann
aufeinandertreffen würden könnte es
knallen aber eigentlich die meisten
leute wie man sieht hier herzen und so
weiter und die meisten sind friedlich
und wollen hier keinen stress ich habe
nicht wirklich bitter die meisten sind
wie die was ist was von der aussage
leben erzählen sie das überhaupt haben
sie grad winkel
na klar war dass die lüge ist jetzt
überhaupt noch nicht friedlich wie man
sieht friedliche leute freundlich oder
auch nicht aber genau wie man vielen
dank an deiner stelle ich weiß gar nicht
was ich dazu sagen soll
vor der kamera beleidigt zu werden
vielen dank an dich wir schauen
natürlich sofort wieder zu dir zurück
falls irgendetwas passiert du
beobachtest dass wir uns ich danke dir
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren